[Música]
en 1991 contó 15 días para divulgar
totalmente todas las armas de sus
masivas
se trataba de un asunto pendiente de la
primera guerra del golfo
y teníamos razón
[Música]
me horroriza haber participado en el de
destruyeron irak
[Música]
[Aplausos]
fue muy rápido habíamos anticipado el
hecho de que la campaña militar no se
alargaría la gran pregunta era qué viene
después
recuerdo haber llamado a mi jefe el
general tres estrellas el comandante del
cuerpo y le dije tengo una buena y una
mala noticia me contestó cuál es la
buena le dije la abuela que controlamos
nadie
dijo formidables felicitaciones cuál es
la mala
conteste web controlamos nadie qué
quiere que hagamos ahora dónde están
esos hombres que nos dijeron white y
había que conducir a bagdad y tomarían
el relevo dijo pues ya meros lo dije me
dijeron que aún se estaban organizando
eso significaba que aún no había
autoridades iraquíes allá para ayudarnos
con eso
[Música]
todo el mundo quería que george bush red
a un héroe y una semana más tarde
comenzó el saqueo y los ciudadanos
iraquíes se dieron cuenta que no había
ninguna autoridad
y ahí empezaron nuestras dificultades
la administración bush no conocía a la
duda
estaba orientada por una determinación
casi mística para sacar a saddam hussein
del poder y aún no ha perdonado a
quienes se les opusieron la forma de
francia fue objeto de una campaña masiva
en todos los medios estadounidenses
hasta abertura y media a américa el
pentágono que se informaba pues detrás
de esa formación
decía francia le vende armas a lanzarse
para abatir nuestros aviones a dar con
un avión
gracias de todo lo posible para que
nuestra operación en conservación de
grupo
los estadounidenses nos prohibían usar
la vía rápida que conducía al aeropuerto
lo que nos obligaba a tomar la vía lenta
cuando había una decena de atentados al
día en promedio
bojan
estadounidenses no tomaban dicha
autopista se desplazaba en helicóptero
exponían nuestra vida voluntariamente es
el fútbol un campo pero una vez en el
lugar los estadounidenses se encontraron
con un país que había que administrar el
jefe de la diplomacia a colin powell y
la consejera para la seguridad nacional
condoleezza rice combinan a la casa
blanca a asumir sus responsabilidades
powell y condoleezza son quienes
convencieron al presidente de que tenía
responsabilidades como potencia ocupante
en virtud de los acuerdos de ginebra y
del derecho internacional
entonces que debía permanecer en
edificarse jerry bremer fue nombrado se
volvió pro cónsul y así sucesivamente
el exdiplomático paul bremer a quien le
decían jerry fue nombrado cabeza de la
autoridad provisional se vuelve de facto
el jefe del estado iraquí y tiene cheque
en blanco' de bus en especial para
llevar a cabo la de basificación el baas
era el partido único bajo la dictadura
de sadam usen un paso obligado para
cualquier cargo de responsabilidad tanto
en el gobierno como en el ejército
armen estaba presente en una reunión
antes de la invasión a irak con el
presidente
y dos decisiones fueron tomadas por el
la primera fue de basificar pero sólo
hasta cierto nivel
la segunda que lanzáramos folletos desde
un avión militar para decirles a los
soldados del ejército iraquí regresen a
casa nos llamaremos guardan una de las
primeras cosas que premier hizo cuando
estaba en irak fue reversar esas dos
decisiones y
desmanteló a todo el ejército
decía sabe lo que quiere decir
esto quiere decir que unos 50.000
soldados de la guardia republicana
regresaron a casa con sus armas
diciéndose
ahora me opondré automáticamente el
gobierno
el departamento de defensa me lo pidió
y me dijo que esto había sido decidido
por el gobierno estadounidense
primer desmiente cualquier
responsabilidad pero dice haber cometido
un error haberles entregado una parte de
dicha tarea a los iraquíes
yo era uno de los miembros de ese comité
de basificación
[Música]
el programa era importante porque era
que estaba dirigido por ese partido
dictatorial y terrorista
no era normal que los libros de ocho
partidos siguieran libres como sucedió
en alemania con los nazis
es por ello que era lógico y natural
aislar y excluir a la gente de la
administración
hay gente que hizo falsas declaraciones
sobre eso
sin que dicha decisión y son caerá el
gobierno iraquí no tiene sentido esta
decisión fue concebida para afectar
únicamente al 2% más importante del
partido
de hecho uno de los resultados fue que
los profesores fueron despedidos
estos profesores tenían la obligación de
pertenecer al partido baas para ser
profesores no representaban una amenaza
y los niños no podían ser educados
porque sus profesores habían sido de
basificados entonces fue un desastre
no hay duda de que había profesores
taxistas
sobre los discursos de sadam husein
y
esos profesores me decían estar en la
universidad en la medida en que sus
investigaciones estaban dedicadas a la
glorificación de los discursos de
sanamente yanahuaya personal el dictador
ha fijado maxia
[Música]
robert granger para todas las semanas a
la casa blanca este responsable de la
cia e informa al presidente bush sobre
la evolución de la situación en irak una
mañana premier se sorprende al ver a
paul bremer en la reunión
paul bremer estaba sentado justo ahí lo
que hizo que la situación fuese un poco
más incómoda porque se explicaba que las
políticas puestas en marcha por el señor
bremen eran un desastre y conducían a
eso pero le dimos nuestro informe al
presidente y el presidente mi nombre me
lo recuerdo como si hubiera sido ayer y
le dijo que contesta frente en su 1er
el señor primer le respondió no veo otra
forma de hacer las cosas distintas al
como lo hacemos fue el final de la
reunión y las cosas siguieran
fue la razón que hizo que muchos
individuos se sublevaran o se volvieran
extremistas
y otros se volvieron verdaderos miembros
de al qaeda
al qaeda en irak que estaba dirigido
inicialmente por zarqaui en 2006
pero es un hecho que esas dos decisiones
fueron reveses catastróficos y
representativos de los que nunca pudimos
salir totalmente
y respeto a los generales
estadounidenses que piensan que fue un
error pero no tenían la responsabilidad
que yo tenía era hacer las cosas como
corregía
paul bremer abandonó dirá que tras un
año en el cargo
el 22 de febrero de 2006 un nuevo ciclo
de violencia golpeó al país
[Música]
la dinamita de la mezquita de samarrá un
lugar histórico desencadenó algo
parecido a una guerra civil con muchos
muertos
estábamos en bagdad con un promedio de
3000 muertos al mes
en el amor
de muchos estados de la región motivaron
a muchos extremistas de diferentes
países a bill a irak
existimos
froome es entregaron cientos miles de
vehículos con bombas de interac de
seplader
wheel
hands
los extremistas lograron acentuar las
tensiones sectarias entre los iraquíes
para hacerle frente a esta ola de
violencia que hunde al país george bush-
acude al general de pechos le ordena el
envío de 30.000 soldados adicionales a
principios de 2007 lo que los
estadounidenses llaman
lo que hizo de eso un éxito no fue el
refuerzo de tropas sino de ideas
weiwei en la forma en la que modificamos
nuestra estrategia y nuestra táctica en
el terreno
hicimos un giro de 180 grados con
respecto a lo que ocurría antes
estaba claro para nosotros que debíamos
regresar a los pueblos para brindar
seguridad a la población si sólo
podíamos hacerlo viviera en tres hay un
nuevo equipo
[Música]
también fue una revelación de prácticas
inhumanas conducidas por el ejército
estadounidense
[Música]
a 20 km de irak al oeste de bagdad la
prisión de abu ghraib era utilizada como
centro de tortura en tiempos de sadam
los estadounidenses tomaron su control
pero no cambiaron su esencia
en la primavera de 2004 unas fotos e
informes le dan la vuelta al mundo
prueban que los soldados torturaron y
abusaron sexualmente de los prisioneros
iraquíes
[Música]
y un error catastrófico es lo que
llamamos un error no biodegradable nunca
se va
tal vez haya un declive en algún momento
pero esas imágenes esas fotos se siguen
en línea y son muy fáciles de encontrar
y eso seguirá siendo una motivación para
aquellos que quieran criticar a estados
unidos
para apoyar las actividades extremistas
bien que aún no es y ellos galvanizó los
alavesistas en ejercían una vez más para
combatir a eeuu durante los años
posteriores a este bien
nunca antes en la historia un presidente
de eeuu autorizó la tortura de seres
humanos y fue lo que george w.bush y
sort
es decir el vicepresidente de dj y del
consejero de este david addington
violamos nuestras leyes internas
violamos el derecho internacional al
torturar gente uno se atribuyó
responsabilidad no son criminales de
guerra si ello quiere decir que debo ir
a prisión como criminal de guerra
mientras ellos vayan tan bien como
criminales de guerra estará bien para
ellos
con el paso de los meses el mundo y en
especial colin powell descubren que los
argumentos para iniciar la guerra
presentados por la casa blanca y el
director de la cia george tenet
eran falaz yo sos
[Música]
recuerdo que en agosto abrió la puerta
de nuestra oficina y dijo escucho lo
último
georg sigue con esas fotos en su
computador
dije las fotos sexuales fotos me dijo si
las fotos de los laboratorios biológicos
móviles siguen allí y dije georges sigue
creyendo que hay laboratorios biológicos
móviles power me dijo pues creo que es
el legado de mi presentación que se
sigue sosteniendo porque todos los demás
se desvirtuaron durante el verano
una semana después viene a verme y dice
george acaba de llamar el último legado
desapareció no hay laboratorios
biológicos móviles estoy sentado y
reflexiono y me digo sabes tú y yo somos
muy ingenios ese es el problema somos
ingenuos
la política puesta en marcha por estados
unidos sembró el caos pero los
responsables iraquíes que los
estadounidenses llevaron tampoco
ayudaron a apaciguar las tensiones
aquí el primer ministro malikí condujo
terribles políticas sectarias que
nuevamente llenaron a los árabes sunitas
los hizo sentir de nuevo desposeídos
otra vez a presentar el fracaso de irak
más que su éxito
y por supuesto ello le permitió al qaeda
en irak hoy en día
recomponerse es entender sencilla
reforzarse militarmente y volver a irak
para poner problemas y
establecer un califato con mosúl como
ese del norte irak
pero no entiendo lo que considera con
errores y
lo que él ve como errores yo lo veía
como buenas decisiones me gustaría que
me dijera cuál es cuando él era
solidario con las adquisiciones
trabajamos en armonía en cada etapa
obtuvimos victorias juntos contra el
estado islámico y el terrorismo y por la
reunificación de irak
la situacion navegará entre lo peor y lo
menos peor con el paso de los años con
algunos avances notables como las
elecciones pero hay una pregunta sin
respuesta la del pecado original de los
mas neoconservadores de la
administración bush
[Música]
creo que la pregunta más importante es
nos vemos
white
porque decidieron ir a irak
es la gran porque
no podía hacer gran cosa y no era una
amenaza para nadie
entonces no veo que nadie nos pueda dar
una respuesta convincente al resplandor
convencen en la cuestión
algunos aún creen que dichas armas
existen
hotmail perdóname pero este gigante
perdóneme por mí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
más
[Música]